bien alors genre de villiers j'ai eu
comme un compte à régler avec vous parce
que vous invitez ici récemment pour
votre livre consacré à la libération des
otages chesnot et malbrunot en présence
de georges malbrunot
et puis j'ai lu dans un magazine
moi j'étais très sympa avec vous et vous
vous dites dans un magazine on a discuté
d'une façon très intéressante et
ardisson se trouvait un peu en dehors du
coup on parler de trucs que lui ne
connaissait pas et le guignol habituel
c'est toi bats lui non plus il pouvait
pas intervenir c'est pas très sympa ça
en est un qui a dit ça dans technikart
j'ai dit ce que je pensais
je vais vous dire moi j'avais été très
sympa mais oui c'est parce qu'en ce
temps-là on va déchirer mais il ya un
truc il ya un truc que je vous ai pas
dit quand vous êtes venu et je vais vous
le dire ce soir tant pis pour vous
fallait pas dire ça vous m'avez accordée
dans des centres de policiers une
vingtaine d'années une interview c'est
pour le journal rock et folk et vous
aviez dit dans cette interview au sujet
de l'apartheid en afrique du sud qui est
un sujet qui nous a occupés ce soir avec
jack lang et mandela
vous m'aviez dit à l'époque je me
sentirai toujours plus proche d'un blanc
qu'on que d'un noir intelligent j'avais
je vous avais dit adorer je vous avais
dit pourquoi et vous m'aviez répondu
parce que je suis blanc on est toujours
plus proche vous savez les noirs sont
plus proches les uns des autres
un an tout au plus proche d'un noir que
d'un blanc et ça n'a rien de raciste
c'est un une simple constatation non
mais aucune maison 20 ans viendra après
vous persistez en disant je me sentirai
toujours proche au rif au regard d'un
daim noir qu'ont non c'est tellement
énorme
je me sentirai toujours plus proche d'un
blanc compte d'un noir intelligent
retirer les épithètes je ne sortirais
germe au plus proche d'un blanc et d'un
noir
tous les noirs sont plus proches les uns
des autres que d'un blanc c'est logique
hein ça vous parle pas été ça veut pas
évidemment moi je me sens plus proche
d'un an
intelligente d'un blanc qu'on perde sa
maman j'en perds
parce que je condamne jean bien je pense
que ça ne souffre d'aucun combien je ne
suis pas sûr de n'avoir ni ce poste je
sois bien sûr vous n'êtes pas sûr que
vous avez dit à technikart vous n'êtes
pas sûr de ce que vous alliez rock les
phoques vous êtes sûr de ce que vous
dites là technikart jamais dit ce que
vous les citer là bas vous regardez le
papier alors dans le même temps m
on peut pas approuver ce truc mais
depuis lors charleville y est gelée a
pris wii est allé en afrique du sud
je vais il est très demandé la voilà il
a découvert ce qu'était précisément un
pays dans lequel chacun respecter chacun
tout à fait noir les asian je suis
finalement malgré ses propos d'il ya 20
ans devenu un admirateur de mandela tout
à fait oui parce qu'il ya vingt ans vous
disiez qu'il y avait eu des blancs en
afrique du sud avant les noirs et qu'ils
étaient plus chez eux en afrique du sud
que les noirs c'est un fait historique
s'est pas fait historique
enfin c'est pas un fait historique
donnant des blues
il est des blancs il ya très longtemps à
ceux qui ont fait la peau a beaucoup de
noirs qui s'y trouvaient notamment des
zoulous mais ça c'est plus au sud à
l'afrique du sud comme un âne le plus au
sud à plus aussi docile que vesoul ou de
l'afrique du sud c'est la flotte oms
noah non c'est le cap
c'est à dire vous arrive de tweets de
dire des trucs bien
alors dans la même interview à rock et
folk ya vingt ans toujours décembre de
police vous disiez les pieds noirs
auraient pu garder l'algérie s'ils
s'étaient battus mais il était trop
indolent il était complètement arabisé
bas ils sont pas battus sauf lors s
était pas lieu c'était pas de la
bataille c'était du massacre inutile et
stupide
non mais c'est pas ça qui est choquant
oui c'est que il était indolent parce
qu'ils étaient arabisé ça pour vous
l'arabe et indolent d'une façon générale
et coûter la vie et pieds noirs étaient
des gens et qui vivait dans un milieu
arabe complètement mais il a des prises
habite d'ailleurs si vous voyez les
pieds noirs et les arabes il vit à peu
près de la même façon les us et coutumes
la façon de lire bon c'est normal ils
ont ils ont réagi les uns sur les autres
bien voilà ce à quoi vous avez échappé
la dernière fois donc il fallait pas
vous plaindre parce que là ça nous est
tombé dessus cette fois-ci voilà bien
alors à part ça vous êtes connu pour
être l'auteur de sas le premier c'était
en 1965 il ya 40 ans est le nouveau le
numéro 158 sort en avril
ça s'appelle tu es iouchtchenko
j'imagine que c'est sur l'empoisonnement
du président ukrainien alors c'est ça se
vend bien parce que le groupe gérard de
villiers vont 750 mille exemplaires par
an ces normes
c'est pas grand chose car le cas en fait
17 millions donc c'est tout petit
comment ça se fait des problèmes
d'argent avec le fisc je n'ai problème
j'ai des contrôles fiscaux
ça ne veut pas dire avoir les problèmes
d'argent avec le fisc vous n'avez jamais
eu de contrôle fiscal si alors mais moi
je leur devais pas 150 millions - quand
ils sont venus me voir pour qui vous
unit joueurs de l'ess en 50p d'euros
c'est dans la presse
à beaujeu la presqu'île pas toujours la
vérité ne voulait pas démentie entre le
cas pourquoi je ne dément jamais ce
genre de choses je ne parle jamais de ce
genre de choses
voilà alors je ne sais pas ce que je
devrais la sortie parce que c'est pas
terminé
donc on verra ce sera peut-être 150
millions ouais mais payez vos impôts
c'était là j'ai pris beaucoup d'impôts
fiscaux
je paye mes impôts c'est tout mais moi
aussi je paie mes impôts maintenant la
preuve ce qui vous cherche depuis 2002
quick et vous croyez que je suis les
gens les gens du fisc ne s'attaque
qu'aux gens qui ne compte aucun cas les
invités comprennent qu'il faut pas te
faire chier un bon pour l'avenir il faut
pas dire il faut pas se mettre dans la
presse quand on a été bien traitée en
tous les cas alors vous êtes ici pour
vos mémoires qui s'appelle sabre au
clair et pied au plancher chez fayard
alors vous donnez votre âge 75 ans jour
pas pourquoi et alors vous préciser dès
les premières pages du bouquin que tout
fonctionne bien
so far so good c'est génial ça c'est
bien à quel âge ça s'arrête moi je me
trompe en voulant garder non mais lui si
par exemple 75 ch et c'est normal je
sais qu'à 75 ans ça va toujours je me
dis c'est bien que ce tiers en vingt ans
voilà
et vous ne tient qu'à 85 ça marchera
encore 200 pastique jean-pierre je vous
demande pas puisque oblige et un bébé
j'avais des choses un enfant tout va
bien tout va bien pour l'instant toile
toujours pas de plainte toujours pas
alors à l'origine vous êtes le fils de
jacques deval auteur dramatique connu
pour tovaritch qui est une pièce
extrêmement successfull dont le vrai nom
est boularan de combat joues tu lançais
un noble et votre mère aussi est noble
elle s'appelle valentine adam de
villiers mais parfois dans certains opus
elle est appelée valentine du pain
pourquoi parce que se plaisent à donnery
du pain de saint-andré d'accord donc
tout ça non je vérifie alors à
l'adolescence vous racontez votre
adolescence dans vos mémoires
vous découvrez la masturbation oui je
suis pas le seul
non mais vous non
vous n'êtes pas le seul à avoir
découvert la masturbation mais vous êtes
le seul à faire des jets d'un mètre
quasiment rien apporté ménages
excusez moi on a remporté pour celles
qui n'ont même pas fait la même chose de
se rassurer vous quasiment à
l'horizontale j'avais 18 ans si si si
alors c'est que vous n'avez pas de baup
a bonne mémoire ou une petite [ __ ] en
tout cas bien décidé à mettre bien avoir
donc ça c'est pour la masturbation et la
voyoucratie vous découvrez aussi un le
trafic de cigarettes le vol de bijoux
les faux lingots d'or vous auriez pu mal
tourner tout à fait appel malte on est
quand même mais bon pas vous auriez pu
plus mal et on est tous à dire alors
vous commencez votre carrière
journalistique dans un journal d'extrême
droite
je suis pas resté longtemps qu'ils
s'appellent rivarol donc dans votre
bouquin et des grands passages
anticommuniste alors c'est voilà tout à
fond voilà des passages anti droits de
l'hommistes si c'est parfois agaçant
quand ça va trop loin - voire un peu
colonialiste certains passages aussi
coloniale il n'a pas apporté que du mal
ouais c'est comme ça c'est curieux
d'ailleurs comment cette tâche en fosse
ont atteint l'extrême gauche est
absolument sacré un mac en minant de
quelqu'un comme arlette laguiller 10
il faut interdire les licenciements
personne ne dit rien tout le monde
trouve ça normal
non mais folle et dangereuse mais pas
raciste
alors après rivarol vous passer par
paris près si vous arrivez à france
dimanche
et là vous sortez ce fameux scoop sheila
est il un homme
moi j'ai interviewé chine a toujours
pour cette série la descente de police
elle était encore traumatisé serge des
interviewés jugent pas combien d'années
après vingt ans après trois tirs et je
raconte d'un mois je raconte dans mon
bouquin comment ça s'est passé
bon c'était pas du tout ni méchanceté
c'est tout simplement 11 et d une sur
celle à toutes les semaines un peu près
à la demande de son imprésario claude
carrère et puis un jour dit goujaud
mettez le recteur en chef ont été voir
carey on n'avait pas d'histoire jetta et
il a eu il a dit elle veut un enfant ne
peut pas voir l'enfant car libre shell
ait un homme ayant eu vent de ces marais
et puis il a fait la une
etc etc et c'est moi vous êtes mis une
seconde à la place de celle à une
seconde une demi-seconde ryad
c'est profondément scandaleux ce que
vous êtes profondément scandaleux et que
vous en rit encore je trouve ça tout à
fait mais par une chose mais puisard
voilà la pâte en le méprisant
on a sorti le papier monsieur carrère
qui était un imprésario de sheila n'est
pas monter au plafond mais monsieur
carrière n'est pas celle là c'est lui
qui nous vendait cher à penser d'abord
aux gens que vous attaquez comme fait ce
genre de pratiques et de riz et voulzy
je vous vois déjà fléchi
je suis pas professeur de morale bon
mais est ce qu est ce que vous vous
rendez compte de ce que vous dites d'une
femme est ce que vous vous rendez compte
de ce que vous dites et que vous
affichez haut et clair avec à cinq
colonnes à la une en dix ans une telle
est un homme c'est profondément
scandaleux il n'avait pas caché que vous
riez aujourd'hui jean-pierre affiche mon
plus profond mais
comme dans pagnol qui le retient pas
bonjour moi je suis là non non mais
enfin va on voit ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
pensent ce qui fait je vois pas pourquoi
je peux partir ça vous ennuie c'est
comme si j'aimerais si tu veux mon avis
je pense que tu es plus utile ici que
non non non mais c'est pas franchement
je suis extrêmement mal à l'aise parce
que vous en pensez mademoiselle enfin
côté de monsieur moi personnellement ça
me choque et ça me chagrine beaucoup à
ce que tu sais pas non plus et qu'il a
inventé le fils d'hitler n'ont pas
inventé le fils dit s'ils n'ont pas non
plus entendu le journal parle d'un fils
d'hitler et il ya je ne lis directeur de
france dimanche débarque à jour disons
beaucoup j'ai vu informations dans le
daily mirror il père avait un fils la
chercher le fils d'hitler voilà j'ai pas
inventé le physique ne vous ai pas
trouvé voilà vous raconter la suite de
votre vie vos souvenirs votre rencontre
avec christina onassis par exemple
paraître jean-edern hallier aussi à un
moment l'elysée vous demande de proposer
à jean edern hallier de publier chez
vous le livre qu'il prépare contre
françois mitterrand
puis voilà puis comme ça vous n'auriez
pas vrai si c'était quelqu'un de
l'elysée mais c'était savez l'histoire
de ce nid sans me tran c'était un roman
extraordinaire parce qu'il y avait
c'était devenu c'était devenu pour
françois-mitterand une obsession parce
que bon évidemment en réalité je pense
que jean edern aurait bien voulu être
ministre et quand ils voulaient me
disais la culture jean edern il n'a pas
été misés laquelle vous vous voyez
françois mitterrand à l'époque où ce
livre était en train de se préparer
je n'étais absolument pas au courant de
tout ça ouais je me suis d'ailleurs
jamais mêler de la vie privée de
personne ni de miséreux des personnes
dont les jeunes finissent par la dncg la
vérité
blanchet
gérard de villiers et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de linars dit tu es abonné
vous mettez un pouce bleus